taxi driver Charles is living in fear
and won't reveal his true name in this
neighborhood in Bujumbura his experience
repeated targeted killings of opposition
members his brother was sentenced to two
years in prison for allegedly taking
part in a protest totaku really for this
occasion the police come and arrest the
people the kuna factual a special police
unit is responsible for this and for
throwing people in prison so the people
here don't trust the police anymore and
that's what's causing the conflict yes
si lo cause valley of coffee bujumbura
can appear calm during the day but at
night gunfire and explosions are heard
throughout the city 6,000 people have
been detained human rights organizations
band but Burundi's government is
downplaying fears of a civil war they
say no one will be persecuted there are
only people who have who are shooting
over the night people who are behaving
as terrorists who are killing innocent
people and throwing bodies into the
streets but they are not Fighting's
because we don't have two sides human
rights activists Denniston daesh mezack
disputes those claims his organization
was banned but he refuses to be silenced
no some are suggesting go game we're in
a state of war we live in a district
where many opposed a third term for
president in currents Issa so the police
are controlling everyone who goes in and
out of my neighborhood tool is okay to
tell asaki dikha de makati a leaner
lives in the district of muta cora the
scene of intense fighting between
government and opposition forces her
children witnessed their father get
taken away in a raid together who's a
good engine towards we can't live
without fear because our country is at
war so of course we're afraid we don't
have a proper gate we tried to block the
entrance to the yard with branch
so we can hear the police coming and
call for help the more than 2,000
homeless children in Bujumbura have no
protection from the nightly violence
UNICEF is supporting 28 shelters for
street children many of whom are
suffering from trauma at night we hear
the shots and we run away the first time
I hid in a toilet the second time we
rented the city center when I was there
I hid with a security guard until
morning the children sent us here offer
a brief respite from the conflict but
the fear of renewed violence remains